okay so i'm talking about immigration uh  at the moment today with uh david  cameron having written in the telegraph  outlining proposals that are really  expanding on ideas that he's either  brought forward or implemented already  so we are cutting talking about cutting  the length of time to which  eu migrants would be entitled to out of  work benefits currently six months back  to three months also making sure that uh  a lot of uh jobs hundreds of thousands  in fact are not advertised on an eu-wide  website and more restrictions on bogus  colleges that's very familiar stuff  ultimately where these two issues of  immigration  and welfare collide is with the  perceived threat of benefits tourism  it's a big issue that has  hemorrhaged votes from the conservatives  to ukip but ultimately if david cameron  thinks he can steal a march on labour  that's the big issue ahead of the  general election